[موسيقى]
بين القانون والديانه والانسانيه الضحيه
صغير يدعى شنوده يبلغ من العمر خمسه اعوام
خسر اسرته منذ عام اب وام حرم من الانجاب
ووجد في شنوده حياه جديده شنوده طفل تبنته
اسره مسيحيه بعدما وجدته حديث الولاده في
كنيسه عاش معهما كاسره محبه لاربع سنوات
يناديهما بابا وماما الامور ظلت طبيعيه
حتى وبحسب والده شنوده خشيت احدى اقارب
الاسره حصول الطفل على الجزء الاكبر من
الميراث فقررت الوشايه وابلاغ الشرطه لكن
ماذا اخبرت الشرطه البلاغ ان الطفل اختطفه
فاروق فوزي والد شنوده بالتبني
واستغلت القانون الذي يقول ان اي طفل
مجهول النسب هو مسلم بالتبعيه لذا تم
ابعاد الطفل عن اسرته وايداعه دار رعايه
تحول
المسيحي الى يوسف المسلم على مواقع
التواصل ينادي المستخدمون بتغيير القانون
مراعاه للانسانيه ونفسيه الطفل التي تضررت
بحسب السيده امال والدته بالتبني بسبب
ابعاده عنها لكن قرار المحكمه الاخير جاء
كطعنه جديده في قلب الابوين المستقبل مبهم
وحتى يتغير القانون سيبقى شنوده في دار
الرعايه وسيضطر اهله لحث اربع سنوات من
ذاكرتيهما